bonjour pierre oswald merci beaucoup
d'être en direct ce matin avec nous sur
rt france vous êtes vous habitez jersey
ça a été une semaine plutôt agitée au
large de sept îles anglo normandes
oui c'était ya un drame c'est qu'il
s'est passé dans l'entrée du camp et des
protestations mais il faut que a
[Musique]
remarqué que je n'ai aucun pouvoir dans
cette affaire
j'ai assisté au à l'accord précédent
mais maintenant je ne pars pas cours
jersey à je veux je peux vous donner mon
avis mais pas de la peur de jersey alors
justement pour l'instant les navires de
guerre ont quitté le large de jersey
est-ce que vous pensez que aujourd'hui
les britanniques et les français vont
pouvoir trouver une solution chaque côté
accuse l'autre finalement de ne pas
respecter les accords du breakbeat qu'en
pensez vous oui je crois que il faut
regarder
l'ancien accord d'accord que j'ai
participé on avait un comité de pêcheurs
des deux côtés il y avait un comité de
scientifiques qui a parlé ensemble et
pour protéger le nombre de poissons
c'est un homme qui sent qu'ils sont
puissants prix est aussi il y avait un
système de à un arbitrage en cas de six
il y avait 2
des affaires qui pouvait pas résoudre il
y avait la possibilité de voir un
arbitrage indépendant alors pour moi
c'est dommage que ça c'est parti entre
entre les deux côtés de cette affaire
que il n'ya pas possibilité de les
comités de résoudre tous les problèmes
et du drame
arbitrage indépendant un arbitrage
indépendant et peut-être plus accessible
sur place parce que là avec le breakbeat
tous les contentieux doivent se négocier
au niveau d'aidé des pays respectifs et
même de la commission européenne ce et
c'est la bureaucratie finalement qui
plombe les relations mais c'était à
l'arrangement qui était voisinage entre
la france et les rosés et c'était un
système qui avait possibilité de
résoudre des problèmes sans avoir des
démonstrations commandes a eu
dernièrement et pour moi c'est dommage
que c'est eux cette question d'arbitrage
n'existe plus il faut prendre un pas en
arrière et remarquer que l'ancien accord
avait deux possibilités de résoudre des
problèmes entre les deux côtés et ça
n'existe plus qu'est ce que vous pensez
du fait que les pêcheurs britanniques
disent qu'ils ont plus de difficultés à
vendre leur poisson en france
aujourd'hui et les pêcheurs français
disent qu'ils n'ont pas assez de licence
pour aller pêcher dans les eaux
britanniques qui a tort qui a raison
selon vous mais à ce problème des deux
côtés ne peut ne peut pas se résoudre
sans un dialogue entre les deux côtés et
ce dialogue devrait avoir lieu
rapidement
mais ce sera au niveau pas comment on
peut sortir sans parler entre nous mais
ça ça se fera au niveau de des
dirigeants au niveau de l'europe
l'ancien accord était la corde borinage
nous sommes couverts les hébreux temps
les normands et j'ai foncé
nous sommes qu aux armes pourquoi
peut-on pas résoudre ce problème avec un
dialogue entre les deux coachs et à ça
il faut poser la question aux dirigeants
effectivement pour avoir un règlement au
niveau local les manifestants
aujourd'hui son son plus sûr sur l'île
de jersey vous espérer une issue
positive rapidement comme j'ai dit je
suis pas en position de pouvoir
maintenant mais c'est ça mon avis qu'il
faut avoir un dialogue entre les deux
coachs et vous avez l'impression d'être
un peu otages du breakbeat finalement
d'être au milieu de ce bras de fer entre
londres et bruxelles
baird
c'est dommage qu'un accord de bouazzi
nage maintenant à s'étaient écartés
avoir bruxelles à paris ou quoi que ce
soit et que des ministres
par exemple le ministre français a dit
qu'ils vont couper le l'électricité
précités
et qui est quelque chose de très sérieux
c'est peu le résultat de ça on peut
demander la question alors on va couper
l'électricité à l'hôpital ou les
ascenseurs ne marche plus et il y a il
ya des ccc quelque chose pour moi que ne
devrait pas se dire que il ya
possibilité de couper le transit et
vacances et quand sport pourrait être
très servir pour l'île de jersey et pour
les gens qui habitent sur cette île qui
achèteraient l'électricité de la france
c'est en défense que on peut couper ça
pour pour résoudre une question qui en
rien à faire avec un éclair avec la puce
est question avec la pêche c'est vrai
merci beaucoup
pierre oswald en tout cas on était
content que vous ayez encore de
l'électricité pour être en direct avec
nous ce matin sur rtl france